there are 2.7 million job postings
requiring project management skills and
more than 70 of them are non-project
manager roles
whether it is a product manager a
developer or a manager of those roles it
is apparent that they often if not
always have to wear a project manager
hat
to succeed projects require an ongoing
battle against a host of challenges such
as changing priorities tightening
deadlines limited resources and
conflicting interests of key
stakeholders
it begs the question how can you
successfully manage projects or lead a
high performance team in today's dynamic
digital world that's why udacity has
created the digital project management
nanodegree program
this nanodegree offers hands-on learning
with real-life digital projects and
digital toolkits to identify compelling
digital methodologies and tools to drive
success
learners will be able to define project
scopes precisely to build resource plans
toward successful outcomes apply best
practices and problem solving strategies
to manage key stakeholders leverage
metrics and emotional intelligence to
ensure the quality of project outcomes
and maximize team performance
are you ready to build impactful digital
project management skills to advance
your career and lead a high performance
team in the digital age
enroll today in our nanodegree to
advance your career in project
management